et comme mes enfants ont l'âge d'être
enfin ils sont étudiants ils pourraient
être parmi vous ils disent en plus que
je suis déjà un vieux geek
donc pourquoi on dit ça parce que il se
trouve que j'ai eu la chance
extraordinaire lorsque j'étais jeune
lorsque j'étais
adolescent c'était en 78 de mettre les
doigts sur un Apple 2 et ça m'a
tellement marqué
que cette passion pour l'innovation
technologique m'a tout de suite envahi
et m'a conduit à créer ma première
entreprise j'avais effectivement 20 ans
à cette époque-là dans la télématique
mais je suis pas du tout ici pour vous
parler de moi et de geek je suis ici
pour vous parler d'un sujet beaucoup
plus intéressant qui est l'hydrogène et
les piles à combustible et comme je vais
pas vous la faire geek en plus je vais
pas vous assommer avec des tas de slides
pyrotechniques mais j'ai amené un livre
et ce livre il est extrêmement
intéressant et il est tout à fait
comment
dirais-je étonnant parce que c'est un
livre de Jules Verne qui s'appelle Paris
au 20e siècle alors ce livre vous ne
l'avez sans doute pas lu parce que c'est
un manuscrit qui a été refusé par son
éditeur il l'a écrit en 1963 il est déjà
au début de sa gloire puisqu'il vient
d'écrire 5 semaines en malallon mais ce
livre est vraiment trop en avant sur son
temps et puis il va disparaître il va
être retrouvé en 1986 dans le coffre
fort de Michel Verne et puis il va être
édité en
1994 et je vais vous en lire un tout
petit morceau
si vous voulez
bien la foule encombrait les rues les
magasins somptueux projetaient au loin
des éclats de lumière électrique les
candélabres établis d'après le système
way par l'électrisation d'un filet de
Mercur rayonn avec une incomparable
clarté ils étaient réunis au moyen de
fil souterrain au même moment les 100000
lanternes de Paris s'alluma d'un seul
coup alors la fiteélectricité déjà passé
par là mais il faut savoir que au moment
où il écrit ces mots là on est très très
loin d'avoir le premier réseau
électrique déployé il faudra attendre
plus de 20 ans supplémentaires avant de
voir des premiers réseaux locaux au
moment où on parle de ça ce qui nous
fait la lumière dans les villes c'est le
gaz de ville et le gaz de ville c'est de
l'hydrogène seulement la façon dont
notre ami julverne voie l'hydrogène est
déjà en
soi très intéressante puisqu'il dit
finalement l'électricité pour
l'éclairage c'est vachement bien mais
l'hydrogène on va faire autre chose
avec de ces innombrables voitures qui
sillonnaient la chaussée des boulevards
le plus grand nombre marchait sans
chevaux elle se mouvait par une force
invisible au moyen d'un moteur à air
dilaté par la combustion du gaz encore
une fois remettons-nous dans le temps de
julverne à ce moment-là on est en 1863
il y a des voitures à cheval et ça fait
seulement 3 ans que l'ingénieur belge le
noir a inventer le moteur à combustion
un petit moteur à de temps qui utilisait
de l'hydrogène et D déjà notre ami
julverne se projette en voyant les
villes envahies de
véhicules alors cette machine inventé en
1859 avait pour premier avantage de
supprimer chaudière foyer et combustible
des bornes gaz établies aux diverses
stations de voitures fournissaiit
l'hydrogène nécessaire ces gaz CAES
comme il les appelle faisaient une
grande consommation d'hydrogène sans
parler de ces énormes aququ chargé de
pierres et de matériaux qui déployent
aussi des forces de 20 à 30 chevaux ce
système Lenoir avait aussi l'avantage de
ne rien coûter pendant les heures de
repos économie impossible à réaliser
avec les machines à vapeur qui dévorent
leur combustible même au temps d'arrêt
alors voilà notre ami il pense à
l'hydrogène comme ça il aurait avec un
peu de chance et au bon moment dans le
temps il aurait pu aussi anticiper autre
chose nous avons de l'électricité nous
avons de l'hydrogène nous avons de la
mobilité pourquoi ne pas envisager la
mobilité sous la forme de l'hydrogène
qui produit de l'électricité il aurait
pu y penser parce que 20 ans auparavant
un anglais Sir William Grove a inventé
la pile à
combustible seulement il manque un
ingrédient dans l'affaire c'est le
moteur électrique et ce moteur
électrique ne sera inventé qu'en 1887
par Nicolas Tesla donc notre ami Jules
Verne n'a pas pu exploiter ça mais je
suis absolument certain que s'il avait
eu connaissance des ingrédients il
aurait tout de suite vu l'avantage de la
situation donc nous somme là alors
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une pile à
combustible
alors je pense que comme moi vous avez
plus ou moins apprécier les cours de
physique chimie à l'École en ce qui me
concerne pas beaucoup pour ce qui relève
des notes mais par contre les
expérimentations les expériences de
physique chimie c'était ça avait un
petit côté magique et en particulier il
y en avait une que vous avez tous fait
c'est l'électrolyse de
l'eau ça a été inventé en 1800 vous
voyez ce siècle les fameux et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on plante des électrodes dans
l'eau on envoie du courant électrique et
sur l'un on va produire des bulles
d'oxygène et sur l'autre des bulles
d'hydrogène et bien la pile à
combustible c'est juste le processus
inverse c'est une oxydoréduction on
amène l'hydrogène d'un côté on amène
l'oxygène de l'autre on enferme entre
deux électrodes on va enfermer une
membrane polymère qui va empêcher les
électrons de passer on va laisser passer
les ions positifs et les électrons ils
vont être forcés de prendre un autre
chemin et hop on va les récupérer et le
résultat de ce
processus c'est qu'on a gagné de
l'électricité à l'autre bout on a
produit de l'eau pure et de la chaleur
en gros pour une pile de ce type de
technologie qui est une pile à membrane
protonique qui utilise de l'hydrogène on
a à peu près 50 % d'électricité pour 50
% de
chaleur donc c'est très intéressant il y
a d'autres aussi technologiques qui sont
disponibles autour des PI à combustible
mais on est à peu près là et puis plus
rien il faut attendre 1953 pour qu'un
certain Francis Bacon se ré réintéresse
à la question des piles à combustible il
en fait une première de 1 kW puis en 59
il en fait une 2è de 5 kW qui va servir
de
modèle pour les piles à combustible
qu'on va envoyer dans les missions
Apollo parce que les ingénieurs
aéronautiques et de l'espace ils ont dit
c'est peut-être beaucoup plus fiable
de produire de l'électricité à la
demande à partir d'un combustible stocké
en l'occurrence c'était du méthane et
qui fait on fait du
reformage plutôt que d'embarquer des
batteries et donc les piles à
combustible sont partis dans l'espace et
sont allés jusque sur la lune et puis à
nouveau grand silence on entend plus
parler quoi que les constructeurs
automobiles des ann ds les années 60
commençaient à nous parler de voiture
électrique et disaient on va commencer
par les voiture électrique à batterie
mais les batteries ça a des
inconvénients et puis on passera à un
moment donné à la pile combustible et
puis le temps passe et toujours rien car
le meilleur compromis de l'époque
économique et technique s'appelle le
pétrole aujourd'hui ça commence à
devenir un petit problème alors vous
trouverez des tas de gens intelligents
qui vous diront l'hydrogène les piles à
combustible c'est un non sens il faut
pas en faire et cetera des gens très
intelligents très compétent ou demeurant
tout à fait estimable mais toute
l'histoire des sciences est là pleine de
gens très compétents et ig qui ont
dénigré des innovations qui se sont
imposé par la suite parce qu'en fait
l'innovation ça demande un petit peu
plus que de l'intelligence et de la
compétence ça demande de la
créativité ça demande de la curiosité et
ça demande de faire confiance à son
intuition
ah moi ce que je vais vous demander à
vous c'est pas de croire sur parole tout
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
mais simplement d'être curieux d'avoir
confiance en votre intuition
ok et vous voyez ça va se passer très
très bien est-ce qu'on peut avoir s'il
vous plaît la petite vidéo que j'ai
préparée parce que malgré tout je suis
quand même un
geek donc voici un
véhicule tout à fait
standardisé qui a été aménagé par une
jeune start-up française qui s'appelle
sybio FS la France effectivement Paron
français on sait faire des choses on
prend donc un véhicule électrique
standard de Renault un Kangou Z2 don
connait les limitations en terme
d'autonomie et le fait qu'il faut
attendre 8 heur pour recharger
entièrement des batteries et on dit ben
voilà ce qu'on va faire on va prendre
une pile à combustible on va occuper des
espaces vides dans la voiture parce
qu'il y a plein d'espaces vide dans une
voiture électrique et on va se servir de
cette pile à combustible pour augmenter
l'autonomie du véhicule en fait on
recharge les batteries et ce véhicule
qui est une première mondiale dans cette
approche hybride
a été choisi par exemple par la poste en
expérimentation dans l'Est de la France
aujourd'hui et permet à la poste
aujourd'hui de tripler les durées de
facteurs les durées des des des tournées
de facteurs donc c'est effectivement
d'un seul coup on supprime tous les
inconvénients du véhicule électrique à
batterie alors il y a aussi des grands
constructeurs internationaux comme
Toyota qui s'apprête à sortir dès le
mois de mars 2015 des véhicules à pile à
combustible sans 100 % pile à
combustible qui seront disponibles pour
l'ordre de 40000 € ce qui est
effectivement très intéressant pour ce
type de véhicule donc les constructeurs
sont prêts on s'est tous préparés à ça
alors pourquoi est-ce que l'hydrogène
c'est bien bah l'hydrogène c'est bien
parce que l'hydrogène c'est un vecteur
énergétique alors vecteur qu'est-ce que
ça veut
dire si on fait un petit peu
d'étymologie d'étymologie on s'aperçoit
que c'est un mot qui un très très très
ancien mot qui vient de l'Indo européen
et qu' a diffusé dans l'ensemble des
langues européennes sauf évidemment le
basque et le hongrois qui ne sont pas
des langues indo-européennes mais
vecteur dans cette langue
indo-européenne ça voulait dire chariot
tiens tiens on y revient on a notutres
petit trucs à roulette le chariot et le
cheval c'est ce qui a permis aux peuples
indo-européens d'envahir la totalité de
l'Europe occidentale à cette
époque donc on a ça après chez les
Latins ça devient vector c'est le
conducteur du char d'ailleurs si on me
rappelle comment comment est-ce qu'on
appelle un fil qui porte l'électricité
un conducteur c'est ça bon j'arrête de
jouer avec les mots parce que sinon on
va on pourrait passer beaucoup de temps
c'est un exercice passionnant mais c'est
pas ça qui est intéressant ce qui est
intéressant c'est que même si on le
trouve effectivement à l'état naturel
aujourd'hui on le sait sur des dorsales
océaniques on trouve de l'hydrogène à
état naturel donc énergie primaire on
sait aussi que dans les zones
aquifères sous la terre on a
probablement des grandes quantités
d'hydrogène disponibles mais
essentiellement on le on on va le
trouver parce qu'on va le fabriquer cet
hydrogène on va le dissocier et une des
façons de le faire et on revient à notre
électrolyse c'est de fabriquer de
l'hydrogène en utilisant les énergies
renouvelables voilà qui est très très
intéressant nous avons envie nous avons
besoin d'une transition énergétique dans
laquelle on va utiliser de plus en plus
de soleil de plus en plus de vent et
voir d'eau dans les limites qui sont
celles qu'on a aujourd'hui pour
fabriquer de l'électricité le problème
c'est que cette intermittence cette
électricité elle est produite à 70 % du
temps quand le réseau électrique n'en a
pas besoin ce sont donc des surplus les
études en cours disent qu'en gros à
l'horizon 2050 avec les scénarios de
transition énergéti que nous avons nous
aurons à peu près 75 TWh par an de
surplu électrique dont on ne saura pas
quoi faire et un candidat extrêmement
intéressant pour utiliser ses surplus
éctrique et bien c'est l'électrolyse
pour fabriquer de l'hydrogène et là d'un
seul coup l'hydrogène devient un vecteur
de stockage de l'énergie qui est
flexible et qui est versatile il joue
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur
énergie mais aussi sur l'ensemble des
applications je vous ai parlé de
mobilité mais aujourd'hui vous avez qui
sortent des petites recharges pour votre
téléphone portable ou votre équipement
de électronique portable
qui sont des piles à hydrogène on ben on
a parlé d'Apple Apple ça fait 2 ans
qu'ils ont déposé des brevets de système
pile à hydrogène pour leurs futurs
iPhon on peut utiliser l'hydrogène pour
fabriquer de l'électricité de façon
stationnaire les fameux centres les Data
Center qui consomment des quantités
absolument astronomiques d'électricité
aux États-Unis sont en train pour la
plupart de migrer sur des systèmes de
pil à combustible stationnaire c'est le
cachet Google chez Microsoft et chez
Apple on a là donc un espèce de de boîte
à outils
l'hydrogène extrêmement versatile
extrêmement flexible qu'on peut utiliser
dans des tas de conditions et c'est pour
ça que je crois moi qui viens des
télécom que l'hydrogène va jouer un rôle
absolument stratégique dans l'avenir
parce que quelque part l'hydrogène est à
l'énergie ce que l'IP a été au réseau de
télécommunication
l'IP s'est imposé partout dans les
réseaux de
télécommunication c'était certainement
pas la meilleure technologie pour
transporter de la voie on vous dira que
la TM 10 fois mieux mais ça faisait
aussi des données mais ça fais ça
faisait si ça faisait ça on pouvait
l'utiliser dans toutes les conditions et
pour toutes les applications et ça ça a
un impact très très très précis en terme
économique ça veut dire qu'on peut avoir
des réductions de coût extrêmement
importants sur les technologies et les
équipements parce parce que plus on
l'utilise et moins ça coûte cher et bien
c'est ça aussi qui va permettre à
l'hydrogène je le crois
sincèrement de s'imposer dans la
société alors les facteurs clés de
succès
pourquoi pourquoi ça arrive seulement
maintenant et c'est pas arrivé avant
alors qu'on connaî cette technologie
depuis
1840 et bien parce que le moment était
pas venu il faut trois conditions réunis
ensemble pour qu'une innovation qui est
une innovation de rupture mais qui en
même temps se substitue à des
technologies existantes il faut trois
conditions remplies pour y arriver la
première c'est que la technologie soit
mature c'est aujourd'hui le cas on peut
le dire la deuxième il faut une
acceptation
sociétale aujourd'hui l'acceptation
sociétale je pense qu'elle est très
claire pour vous la pollution la santé
la fin de l'air du pétrole la fin des
ressources de ce type là tout cela
impose dans votre esprit à vous la
nécessité de bouger
et le troisième facteur c'est qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un business model faut
qu'économiquement parlant tout ça ça
tienne debout il faut que des acteurs
économique dans le marché trouve un
intérêt à continuer à investir pour
améliorer la maturité technologique et
puis pour déployer ces applications là
aujourd'hui je le crois vraiment c'est
mon intuition
d'innovateur que le moment est venu que
ces trois facteurs sont réunis ensemble
et que l'hydrogène dans les années à
venir vous allez en entendre énormément
parler
alors moilà ce que je voulais vous
transmettre moi moi aussi j'ai des
messages à transmettre euh ce qui est
très important pour arriver à faire ça
pour qu'on y arrive il faut de la
volonté il faut de
l'envie il faut le désir de faire les
choses et une certaine forme de
nécessité la nécessité elle est connue
de tous il est temps de changer de
paradigme énergétique je vous
remercie